rah Vargas Josh do you realize it in the
more than five years we've been working
together we've not done a single stock
market cover yeah I guess so kind of
amazing yeah it's strange and the reason
of course is a pretty entire abama
presidency we've had zero percent
interest rates and the market has source
slowly steadily crept up until the last
few weeks so we had a lot of stuff that
we could have thrown in the mix for the
cover this week there's a great opening
remarks essay by peter coy he sort of
traces market panic beginning in China
all the way through very very smart
piece yeah I mean I think you just said
bear bear and then we found bears yeah
we tried a bear but why have one bear
when you can have when you can have a
hundred there yeah Wow how many images
we have here I think there's about 40 so
we've 40 individualized silhouettes of
bears and just so people know it's not
as simple as just cut pasted place like
each one of these has to be treated I
think it comes off really well and it
matches up so very happy about that did
you read our story about Jean Friedman
the taxi came okay so pretty interesting
this is the guy who as far as we know
owns the most taxis in America obviously
stands to lose the most from uber is 44
years old very very smart it is the rare
story that actually features comment
from our owner because Jean Friedman is
in an engaging litigation against the
city of New York and Mike Bloomberg so i
would encourage people to read our
owners comment as well as the story it's
terrific and the comment may be
surprising yeah if i was to point to one
other story i would say diamonds
basically this is an amazing piece
leading our market section about
artificial diamonds and they're made in
a lab the only way you would know the
difference is if you are a chemist
they're significantly cheaper than
regular diamonds and they're really
beginning to take off not just because
people are looking for more affordable
means that it getting diamonds but
frankly they're new and interesting so
it's a really really smart story it's a
you know what I give us a sort of an e-
this week like I think the nice things
packed was really pretty nasty things
are some some some
news extent yes for a for a change while
the markets are cratering and wealth is
being destroyed around the world there
is also the occasional bit of good news
for late August okay